Look at each of these profitable trades.
They all look almost the exact same.
They are reversal trades that are
happening at the exact same time in the
day. Now, I've discovered something
about the US markets that has become
incredibly predictable and repeatable.
It allows me to trade only 60 to 90
minutes in the morning to consistently
find profitable trades every day before
going to my full-time job teaching
people how to trade. And it hasn't just
worked for me, it's worked for a ton of
other people and has stopped them from
jumping from strategy to strategy,
ending their years of struggle with
trading. They finally found something
that is consistent and works for them.
And later, I'll tell you about a $20,000
trading competition prize pool that you
can join for free a little bit later in
the video. Now, I've narrowed this down
to three powerful market patterns and
tricks most people overlook. Once you
know all three, you will never look at
the market the same way again. You will
consistently be able to spot profitable
trades in the market. And I'll show you
a trade that I recently took that has a
bonus insight that will bring this all
together for you. Now, I consistently
lost money trading for years. And here's
why. I wasn't looking for a specific
pattern to trade. I wasn't patiently
waiting for my trading plan to play out.
Instead, I was consistently trying to
catch every move that the market had.
Afraid of missing out on potential
profits. My approach was chaotic. I
jumped into trades just because the
market was moving, hoping I could catch
a quick win. But it never worked. My
trades were rushed based on guesses
rather than waiting for a clear plan.
And I consistently lost money over time.
And I know a ton of other traders are
stuck in this cycle, too. And that was
me for years. But then everything
changed for me. I learned to be
consistently profitable because I
learned to wait for a specific pattern
and key factors to show up in the
market. I learned to become patient,
willing to sit on my hands if those
setups didn't appear. Some days I take
no trades at all. And that's what
finally gave me an edge trading. Instead
of reacting to the what the market did,
I instead waited for the market to come
to me. And when I was ready and
confident in a setup, I would take it.
That's how I was able to consistently
start to make money and stop losing
money. So, let me walk you through the
three secrets I use every day before
taking a profitable trade. Now let's
jump into the first pattern which is
probably the most crucial biggest
observation I have ever made about how
to get an edge in the market. Now if you
don't couple it with the second secret
though it kind of won't matter. It
really needs to be combined with a
couple of other things. Now, when the
market has a massive move in one
direction, most traders, my older self
included, get too caught up thinking of
how can I jump in this move and capture
some of this money. I've already missed
out on a massive amount of money I can
make. But I realized over time is I
would always be jumping in right when
this move actually reversed because
after a massive move a lot of the times
this is usually when the market baits
people in because it's actually
overextended at that point and it needs
to have some kind of healthy pullback.
The market likes to move in healthy
methodical movements. Every move up has
a counter move with a healthy pullback.
This is how a stable trend operates. An
unstable trend is when it shoots in one
direction extremely quickly. And when
that happens, it's likely to fail and
have what I like to call the rubber band
effect. Because to become healthy again,
it needs to have a pullback into that
more equilibrium type of healthy trend.
And using that knowledge of looking for
massive moves in one direction without
pullbacks, we can start to see where
opportunities of potential snapbacks can
be. Now, this second secret is even more
crucial because it times your entries
with big players and market movers. And
secret three will show you the final
pieces that ties it all together, giving
you the ability to consistently find
highreward opportunities while avoiding
a ton of false signals that will
potentially lose you money. Now, here's
the thing. Most traders don't realize
the market actually likes to bait them.
Just like with that big rubber band
effect where the market will move up,
get overextended, and snap back. At 8:30
Eastern Standard Time, when the US stock
market opens, big players like hedge
funds and institutions come in and push
the market hard in one direction, which
tempts traders to jump in thinking that
they're going to catch a big move for
the rest of the trading day just when it
opens. But that move often sets them up
for a reversal and a bait in the
opposite direction. This baiting effect
often repeats and is the reason timing
is so crucial. This timing that I've
noticed often happens 30 minutes after
the US market opens. And I've tracked
this pattern over years and it often
happens three out of five trading days.
Knowing this timing lets you anticipate
when these moves are most likely to
occur and it allows you to drown out the
noise and patiently wait for what
matters. And so I've actually created a
30inut reversal strategy guide that
shows you multiple setups with this
timing and how you can execute easily
based with that. And you can download it
with this QR code or via the link below.
And when you combine this precise timing
with the rubber band effect, you're no
longer guessing when it comes to
trading. You're trading with a clear
plan and edge, which helped me turn
myself from a consistently losing trader
to now having a consistent plan that I
can execute every day. Now, let's jump
into a real trade example here so I can
illustrate to you the timing, the rubber
band effect, and as well as the final
piece that brings everything together.
So, first off, you can see the market
opens for me in my time zone at 7:30
a.m. So, right here, the market opens
up. The market has a big move in one
direction without much in terms of
pullbacks. And so, think about the
rubber band effect. It's likely to have
some sort of pullback because this is an
unhealthy move. And then, if you couple
that with, well, 30 minutes after 7:30
is 8:00. And so what happens here is
this starts to has its move up and then
starts to slow down at 8:00. And so that
would be a really good two indicators
that this thing is likely to slow down
and have a pullback in a big way. And
instead what I like to look for as my
third key is that it comes up into what
I have here is a big resistance zone.
So, you can use this strategy either
betting the market's going to go down or
betting that the market is going to go
up. And so, I was able to use those
three things of the big rubber band
move, the timing, and then a big
resistance zone. And those paint the big
picture that it's likely to have a big
move up, slow down, and snap and give
that back lower. And you can use that to
capture a lot of money. I made about
$3,000 on this specific trade. Now, to
tell you about the prize pool, Ninja
Trader, the platform I use here, is
having a $20,000
trading competition. You can join with a
demo account, basically risk-free trade
in this competition. It lasts for 5
days, so it's actually over pretty
quick. starting September 14th, which is
a sick way to practice trading in a
risk-free environment, but also be able
to make some real money to start a
trading account for yourself. So, you
can sign up for that using the link
below or this QR code. Now, let me walk
you through a full trade example so you
can really understand how I use these to
enter in when I see this setup. This
doesn't happen every day. Again, trading
is hard to make this consistently work.
And so that's why for me, what made
trading work for me was patiently
waiting for this setup to happen. And
so, let me walk you through another one
just to show you how repeatable this
really is. And so, here 7:30, the market
opens up. And so, at that point, I'm
just watching. I'm waiting. I'm I I want
to just see how does the market open up?
What is it doing? And generally, I will
have key areas of support or resistance
drawn off of a 15-minute chart. And then
I like to watch and trade on a one
minute chart. So, right here, we're
watching a one minute chart, but you can
see it's come down into a support level.
And so, I'm just sitting here waiting
for that timing to show up. And one
thing is when you're counter trend
trading, the difficult part is knowing
when it's going to reverse. And that's
why waiting for a big support zone to
happen. And you can see it's blasting
through a couple of these support zones.
There's one here. It blew through. And
so it's waiting for that timing and as
well as seeing how it reacts to those
levels. But then also a big picture idea
is okay when is this downtrend broken? I
like to use trend lines a lot of the
time. I like to also use the highs and
the lows of the swings. As the market
trends down, it's making lower lows and
lower highs. And when it shifts to an
uptrend, it's going to start making
higher highs and higher lows. And so, I
like to try and capture and jump in kind
of in this area when it started to show
that it's potentially reversing. And so,
you can see here it's broken. It started
to break that trend line. And it happens
pretty quickly. And so that's why you
want to be laser focused when it happens
and it gets to these areas. And if you
ever watch my live training videos, I'll
be walking around in corners of the
room. I'll be doing stretches. I'll
leave the room. But when it comes to
your area that you're really looking for
an opportunity, you want to be dialed in
on what it's doing. Because what I'm
seeing here is it's come down to a
support level. This trend is clearly
over. Not even just looking at the break
of this downtrend. the fact that look at
the candlesticks, right? Red, red, red,
red, red, red. And then it started to
have a bit of a pullback. There's some
green in here. There's a lot of dogeis
and choppy candlesticks. It's
essentially showing you that the
momentum has started to slow down. And
when momentum starts to slow down at a
key area like this, it's likely that
it's going to find some strength and
move higher and reverse. And that's what
I like to see. And so big picture,
there's a nice double bottom here. If
you get that 30 minute reversal guide,
you'll see most of the examples in
there. Use and have a double bottom. So
those double bottoms are really key. And
the last thing is to jump in here. What
you use as a final confirmation to jump
into a trade is really, really tricky.
It's hard to know exactly when, okay,
when do I jump in? Because, you know, if
you could say this was a double bottom,
if you jumped in here, jumped in here,
jumped in here, you know, a lot of times
you're going to have false signals. And
so, the way I like to enter in, it
allows me to try and avoid some false
signals cuz sometimes these will set up
in double bottoms and they'll just kind
of continue lower. It'll just be a slow
in the momentum. And so learning how to
spot the difference between, oh, this
trend is just kind of slowing down and
it's going to continue lower and making
a bare flag it's called, versus it's
slowing down and it's lost that momentum
and it's going to gain momentum and
switch in the other direction. And so
for me, what I like to use is I like to
see some kind of failed attempt to
continue lower. And so this double
bottom I think does that. this red
candlestick here that broke this double
bottom low I think does that and then it
starts to have a nice bullish
candlestick here and it makes a kind of
a bearish candlestick actually right
here. So essentially what the market's
done is it's popped up here and it
started to make a pullback. And so I
think is well if it's going to continue
lower it might just start to do this.
But if it's going to continue higher I
think it's going to probably break this
high. And that's a nice spot where I
think once it's done that that's enough
confirmation for me. So that's why I
have a buy stop order here that
essentially gets me in a market order
once the price hits that level. And so
it it's essentially a way to jump in via
momentum versus waiting for a pullback
and getting in on a limit order. And so
I jump in on the trade and at that point
I put my stop in a place that I think
makes sense based on the previous lows
here and this double bottom. So
essentially, if it hits this double
bottom again, I'm happy to get out. I
think at that point, you know, the idea
of I'm going with the structure of the
market and that's when you want to get
out of the trade because you can see
here it's going to have some pullbacks.
Nothing just goes straight up in one
direction or straight down in one
direction very often. That last trade I
showed you very quickly, it went
straight down, but it took about 20 or
30 minutes to really get going. And so a
lot of the times because the market's
still at this area gaining strength and
at an inflection point, you know, it's
not sure what it wants to necessarily
do. There's a lot of sellers still
wanting to get in. You know, people that
are, you know, old me and maybe you that
see this big move and think, well, it's
consolidating here and I won't think
it's going to continue lower, so I'm
going to jump in. And so that's pushing
the price down here still or keeping it
lower. But then there's people like me
coming in saying, "Hey, well, I think
we're at a good level." And so that
balance is happening, making it so the
market's just sitting here and chopping.
And then eventually some imbalance
happens. You know, those sellers start
to dry up, a lot of buyers come in, and
it pushes the market higher. And so, you
know, it doesn't always take that long,
but sometimes, you know, trade on a one
minute chart, even 5 minutes or 10
minutes of just sitting in this chop can
feel like a decade, but at that point,
you know, I just managed to trade how I
see fit. It to me, it felt like the
market was just going to pop up here and
maybe come back. It felt a little
choppy. I didn't think that it was going
to go much higher. And so, I jumped out
here getting about $750 in the span of,
you know, 30, 45 minutes. and then I
move on with my day. And so, if you want
to take this strategy to the next level,
make sure to get that free reversal
guide in the description below. Also,
check out Ninja Trader. I've used it for
years. It's super good. And if you want
an even more detailed walkthrough of
this strategy, check out this video
right here. It's an over an hour long
and it's going to explain everything you
need to know.